[Music]
yes
everyone i'm john raphas and welcome to
a special studio broadcast
chances are you've been jamming on all
the content that was dropped with our
season one reloaded update
well good news you ain't seen nothing
yet
this week season two arrives and
delivers new cold war zombies and
multiplayer experiences
features new warzone updates new
operators new free weapons
new battle pass content and more today
we're going to connect with the members
of the treyarch and raven development
teams to talk about all things season
two
and it's going to start with the story
lines driving the action
earlier we were able to catch up with
treyarch's miles leslie as well as
ravens ryan burnett
and this is what they had to share
1984 and the vodanoy ship has just left
rebirth island with some precious cargo
unfortunately for the captain and its
crew it will never reach its final
destination
it'll be gone lost at sea for 37 years
to one day
it appears crashing into verdance
what it brought with it well some new
friends
good make them believe we care about the
number six supply lines
let's talk about where the black ops
story is heading across war zone
and cold war in season two and all the
awesome content that comes with it
last we left our operators in season one
adler was taken captured by stitch
the team's gonna need some
reinforcements to help him so woods and
crew
enlist the help of terrell wolfe now
wolfe is the ultimate hunter
he can stalk any prey and find him so
he's the perfect man for the job to help
find adler and the nova 6 threat
this leads them to the jungles of laos
where they believe that adler's being
held and you're going to need someone
else that knows the jungle another guy
that's where
carla rivas comes in she knows firsthand
with these
cartels that run through the jungles and
perseus and what they've done and she
wants to take them out she's got her own
personal agenda
and she also knows that she's got to
find adler and shut this down
now they are going into the backyard of
naga now naga is a perseus commander he
works under stitch and he
is a deadly predator this guy knows the
jungle like the back of his hand
so the team is gonna be really up
against it
when they face naga so we have this new
location at the launch of season
two it's right between the gulag and the
port
it's a location that is close quarters
it's tight there's multiple elevations
you need to keep your head on a swivel
but hopefully you go there you get those
rewards and get out
we also have something that we've teased
since the beginning of our dance
we're finally opening them up to the
users a lot of them go in there and
explore
start to unravel some of the stories
some of the mystery around this
this island so we're finally opening up
these areas and we're excited to see
what fans do with us
coming launch week is a brand new
limited time mode that we have
that's called resurgence extreme what
makes it so extreme
is that we're more than doubling the
number of players that come into the map
here
you thought that plane resurgence was
action-packed
high combat before we have twice as many
people in there it's really incredible
you're gonna be in combat pretty
consistently there's no hiding out
there's no place that's safe there
so another game mode that we have in
season is called exfiltration so
what's really cool about this is we've
implemented an alternate way to win the
game so rather than just take out
all the enemies and combatants there if
you find this radio and you hold on to
it for a certain amount of time you can
call into excel
win the game and get out of the map
before everyone else we have
so many things planned throughout this
season here it's going to culminate
an amazing experience towards the end of
the season
[Music]
now when you talk about amazing
experiences in season two it's
impossible not to talk about
zombies as well so here to talk about
all things undead
including outbreak are members of the
zombies team quirky
kevin craig gentlemen welcome
hello hello all right here we go
hi john you guys craig we're gonna kick
things off with you
season two sees a continuation of the
dark ether storyline
if you could bring us along on the
journey from season one
to where we find ourselves now in season
two
well i think i said in one of the last
streams that you know
d machina really was kind of a story
that was built on
the past the requiem team finding out
what had gone on during world war ii
and the experiments that have led to
these dimensional breaches from the dark
ether
and then when we moved into firebase c
it was much more of a kind of
current active situation with uh
characters in the level
uh obviously ravenoff and dr peck we all
got to meet
and i think narratively this really
shows just the the scale at which this
this cold war arms race between requiem
and omega is is starting to
boil over we've teased a little bit
about the euro mountains
and uh these large-scale breaches are
going to be the kind of battleground for
investigation and scientific experiments
to make sure that requiem
do not fall even further behind
omega than they already have well
whenever you talk about
large scale it seems like that that
really tease things
up for the the the big experience this
season which is
outbreak right and quirky maybe
you know you could tell us a little bit
more about what outbreak is all about
what's in store you know i've been the
creative director on zombies since world
of war
and um you know it's it's always come up
every project like hey let's do an open
world zombies
and you know i'm just really excited
that for
cold war we had the opportunity to do
this you're able to complete objectives
and build your your power as you go i
think it's important to say that
this mode is an entirely new way to
experience
zombies for the first time ever you're
in these massive spaces
and you're moving through them as
opposed to zombies coming to you
you're moving and exploring and
discovering things along the way and
you're encountering
zombies and enemies and what is driving
you that entire time
is completing these objectives that
requiem has sent you in there to
to finish along the way you're going to
encounter familiar enemies but at the
same time
sabram new enemies that we haven't seen
in cold war
the first is the tempest which is this
electrical
crystalline being that really plays to
the strengths of this mode
because he tosses projectiles at you
and warps around within within the
massive space and then we also have the
krasny soldat
we find ourselves constantly um losing
time
when we're playing the game we're just
sitting there and having fun
exploring and driving and using jump
pads
to parachute i think the fact that kevin
mentioned driving
it just changes things there's something
very satisfying about
plowing the vehicles into a horde of
zombies and um
seeing them ragged all out of the way uh
that that's fun tell us a little bit
more about how
tier 4 and tier 5 uh abilities kind of
get unlocked
and expand the game play with the
requiem advancements we've been able to
expand
the powers of all of our skills so there
are now
tier four and five and you have to go
discover and find
two new types of crystals to unlock
these the refined and flawless
this has been an awesome opportunity to
go and look at all the the various
skills the content the perks the field
upgrades
and find ways to strengthen them
for example all the the ammo mods now
their tier fours
allow the the ammo mod to affect
specials
um so what that means is now you could
potentially brain rot
a mangler or a tempest or even a mimic
that is the the most exciting thing for
me is that that brain rot
and turning into mimic and having him
fight on your side
for once and and a mangler it's really
cool
see i thought kevin was just listing off
his nicknames for
uh you and me corki
okay craig over to you now what what are
you most excited about
i i am neither refined nor flawless um
but no again i was saying before it
really does continue the story so we
actually get to see
uh our support and cast you know dr
strauss
dr gray and um major carver
they've got objectives that need to be
carried out you know
there's a narrative element that i think
is is kind of fun because it is
more of a military and scientific
operation where you are
undertaking these various tasks and
experiments
and objectives that are going to
hopefully give requiem a better insight
into how they can use and potentially
harness the powers of the dark ether
rather than just having to
react to it samantha maxis makes an
appearance
this season as an operator if you could
tell us a little bit more about
what that appearance is all about how
that works maxis has been
in the field you know throughout the
entirety of our cold war story and
unfortunately in firebase c dr william
peck
confessed to throwing her into the dark
ether and she's been in there for
an indeterminate period of time because
we've already explained that time moves
differently within the dark ether so
when she comes back
she's definitely changed i think the
first thing that people will definitely
see is that
her eyes look pretty cool they have you
know elements of the dark ether within
them but
part of the ongoing story is uh going to
be just a little bit about
what has happened to her and what that
would mean for the future
after the events of firebase e she's
also going to become a playable operator
not just in zombies
but across our other modes as well and
um
i'm looking forward to that enormously
just because i
know it has been requested kevin i
i think we'd be uh remiss if we didn't
talk a little bit about
the death machine uh that that should be
coming along here in season two as well
i think this is a zombie's classic it
makes its return
this game to unleash devastation against
the horde
and it's going to be super useful to
have this
and some of these objectives and
outbreak where they're in interior
environments and you can't necessarily
rely on the
the air based um support
i know that in season two uh the team
begins introducing
uh some new weapon skills some special
some launchers uh what's in store for
players on that front
so as we kind of open up the the play
space and we've been adding more and
more specials
and elites the special and launchers
uh weapons uh will gain weapon skills
that allow them to deal more damage to
higher
difficulty and enemies as well as like
deal more damage uh to their armor so
karen now this is kind of a new option
is like i want to bring a launcher or
the crossbow around because it's
actually very good at taking out
the megaton or the krasny sold at so it
adds a lot of value to those weapon
classes
the newest field upgrade that we're
going to be adding
to the mode is is frenzy guard what it
does is it draws the
attention of all the zombies in the area
so they'll attack you
but as you power it up it gives you all
these tools to deal with the entire
horde attacking you so it's replenishing
your armor
and eventually at its highest power it's
slowing all the zombies in the area
and it's extremely useful in objectives
where you have a situation where
potentially
you know a lot of zombies are attacking
the the defend console
and you just want to pull them all off
and make sure that you know
you're going to be able to complete that
objective just out of curiosity
as the team has been play testing out
break what are you most
interested in people being able to play
themselves
someone on the team who shall remain
nameless talked about a game they had
last week and described it as the most
intense frightening experience they'd
ever had in zombies when they were
trying to
ex-fill after they felt they've been
doing great but they described the
experience of running up a hill
feeling that they were about to get out
of there and everything was fine and
then were
met with uh advancing horde on a
on a scale that we we don't really see
in the kind of more
room-based corridor-based kind of um
typical
round-based maps guys thank you very
much for joining us today
thank you john thanks john thanks john
and that brings us to multiplayer which
means that we are joined by none other
than treyarch's tony flame and matrons
to talk weapons maps
and modes gentlemen welcome
thanks john i'm super excited to talk to
everybody about
all the cool stuff we got coming a lot
of fun tools for everybody from the
weapons side
well good let's just capitalize on that
excitement jump right in
let's talk about what's happening on the
weapons front starting launch week it
sounds like that there's an ar and an
smg coming
coming everybody's way that's how we're
starting we know people love
assault rifles and smgs as you can see
we're hanging out in the jungle here and
that's going to be a little bit of a
theme
as we go through all the fun new toys
that are coming out for season two
so the assault rifle that we have coming
out launch week is called the farah 83
and it's a really unique weapon system
it's intended to be a long-range assault
rifle
it's going to have a good fire rate it
can cross over into the lmg category a
little bit what lmg's are going to hold
hold in a point but of course compared
to an lmg the fera 83 is going to have
much better handling speeds faster ads
times things like that
now the trade-off is compared to other
assault rifles it is a little bit slower
on the handling and it has a little more
recoil that you need to master
for those long-term engagements but once
you get that recoil down then you're
going to be able to
lock down long lanes with this assault
rifle
as well as have the the ability to go
full auto and close range and medium
range so
it's a great it's a great all-around
weapon tell us a bit more
about the lc10 lc10
so the lc10 is really cool it's a
submachine gun that excels at long-range
combat and the way that it does that
primarily because it has an extremely
fast fire rate
is that it has a higher muzzle velocity
so those smg bullets you might notice
when you use submachine guns because
they have that lower muzzle velocity
it takes time for bullets to travel
downrange to hit distant targets
well the lc10 has a higher muzzle
velocity so those bullets are going to
travel faster
get to your targets quicker you don't
have to lead as much
fictionally this is a weapon that was
designed by the same manufacturers as
the lw3 tundra
so we had a lot of fun making kind of a
submachine gun version of that weapon
whenever you talk about sort of like a a
weapon that is inspired by sort of like
a class or a type
what's it like collaborating with the
with the weapons team to kind of like
bring that to life i have to imagine
that it the process is a lot different
than
sort of a historical weapon well we have
just an incredible uh
weapons art team here at treyarch so
they're always looking for to give each
gun
you know a real identity in this case
something that we made
um but that still has its own place in
the game
so because we had an established weapon
with the tundra
and it has that's of course a
manufacturer needs to make that weapon
manufacturer's not just going to make
one weapon so we're always looking for
the story
behind each gun and each each weapon is
its own unique story
um and it's it's important for it to
have that individual identity
well when it comes to telling stories uh
or weapons telling stories
uh what kind of story would the shadow
hunter tell us the r1 shadowhunter
is our 1980s version of the crossbow so
you might recognize that name as a
predecessor
for what would later become the
shadowclaw crossbow in black ops 3.
this is where it started with the r1
shadowhunter this is a crossbow that's
perfect for the jungle
it's going to be stealth it's going to
be quiet manually operated
you can retrieve your blades and these
are projectile blades that
have that are going to kill directly on
impact anywhere in the body
now to combat that because it could be
you know
something you have you get in one shot
we want to provide a counter for
everything whenever we can
so if you have armor equipped you will
survive that hit
and this is just a classic storied
weapon in call of duty history
and we have to make sure that we always
have a
crossbow in a black ops game also
coming in season is a new sniper rifle
it's the uh
zrg 20 millimeter correct so the zrg 20
millimeter yes it's in the name
20 millimeter um it's a pretty massive
ordinance to be firing
larger than any other sniper rifle in
the game so as you might imagine
this is the highest damage sniper rifle
in cold war
this is going to kill enemies anywhere
above the waist
so you get that shot on target with this
thing and it's good night
so this is pretty scary to put out a big
sniper rifle like this that's this
powerful we have a lot of skilled
snipers out there
so on the flip side you're gonna have to
make sure that that shot counts
you're only going to get three shots in
a magazine which is
which is how these rifles were actually
manufactured those rounds are massive so
to carry around more than three in a
magazine
is just too heavy so there's three
rounds in a magazine and the re-chamber
time is rather
it takes longer than the other sniper
rifles so we'll be keeping a close eye
on the balance after it comes out but
this thing is an absolute beast
it looks absolutely menacing in your
hands
and it's going to sound menacing as well
we hope you enjoy this one
well also in season it sounds like the
team is delivering uh
some melee items including a machete and
an
e-tool of course if we're going to the
jungle you have to have a machete it's a
necessity
now the machete has some unique melee
properties it has a long stab
when you are uh getting an attack on an
enemy
now the trade-off there is that it's
slower to swing so while
much like the sniper rifle while it's
more powerful and has more range
you're going to want to make sure that
you engage that melee attack at just the
right time so that you don't have a
missed attack that takes longer to
re-engage
but other than that the machete is
perfect for the jungle and
for getting those close encounters so
tony earlier the
the zombies crew was talking about this
new score streak that's coming
to season two if i'm not mistaken we've
got
the death machine on the way yeah i
think the 80s broke the record for most
miniguns in movies of a decade so of
course we have to bring the death
machine back it's also
a black ops staple as many of our fans
know for some personality we added an
ammo can
and a feed bag on the bottom just to
give it a little bit more heft and
weight in first person a little bit of a
unique look
but it's going to feel as powerful and
menacing as ever
now as a scorestreak for anyone that may
not know this
when you're using a scorestreak weapon
then any kills that you get
will count towards your your score
streak multiplier and you'll continue to
get more score for every next kill in
that life of course the trade off there
is if you die with the scorestreak
weapon in your hands then you lose it
it's a high risk high reward super
satisfying weapon to use
as the death machine is we have to get
it right every single time
and then believe we've done so this time
all right
well let's switch gears let's talk about
maps and modes let's bring in matt into
the conversation
uh matt let's talk about some stuff
that's available launch week starting
with the 6v6 experience apocalypse
what's going down sure um hi john
let's talk about apocalypse fictionally
for apocalypse
uh we're actually raiding naga
stronghold and we're trying to find
that damn adler who's always up to his
hijinks and still trying to find out the
fun trying to find some clues about the
nova 6 threat that seems to be
continually looming it's a 6v6 map so it
is on the smaller side
uh but there's a lot of different ways
to to find enemies and engage
there's some some really interesting uh
connectivity paths
uh throughout the map so you're gonna be
able to go through the
really cool temples uh you've got little
candles set up and and connecting paths
to the center
you can barrel straight down the the
middle dirt road
and then you've got the huts uh so the
huts are are up on stilts
uh you can kind of make your way through
there and it's a bit of a safer path
uh and then we've got some really
interesting flank routes uh where
there's been a chopper that's been
downed
so you'll be able to flank through that
chopper and and hopefully
get behind your enemy and get a nice
advantage on them
so if if 6v6 scratches that sort of
smaller map [ __ ] it sounds like we've
got a bigger experience
in fact the 40 player experience coming
later in the season uh
we're going to golova so this is one
that outbreak players are going to
be on season launch and then our high
player count players will be able to
experience that
later in the season fictionally you're
going to look at this map and say oh
that's a nice little
rural russian mountain town the story
behind it's
a little more dicey where actually
these soldiers are born and bred from
birth
to be trained killers you're going to be
moving through the russian town
some of the points of interest are going
to be the the neighborhood which is
where that density comes from
uh the train station you're going to be
you know roaming around a church
and then there's a farm which kind of
opens up so the the inside of the map is
a bit more dense
you're going to be able to get in some
closer range engagements than you you
may be accustomed to
in our previous maps but once you get
kind of on the outskirts that's where
you may want to take one of those fancy
new snipers
and and see if you're going to land a
few shots the the importance for us was
to create a very
uh different type of gameplay than you
may have seen in in the maps like
ruka uh or alpine or or or our
previously released
season one sanatorium um which you know
sanatorium just to speak on that
we saw a lot of positive cinnamon on
that um so
that continue the feedback because that
does help us that does inform us
where we go next uh in season it sounds
like the team is also delivering two
other map experiences man
mansion and miami strike tell us about
those mansion is actually based in
havana
cuba um and it's based off of the
uh cold war campaign mission and the
line you're going to start
inside of the mansion and you're going
to be fighting your way towards each
other
through this kind of open middle room so
that middle room is going to be a little
dangerous
but you're going to have an upper flank
path that does require a mantle up
if you want to take the risk of mantling
up there you're going to get a good
vantage point
of the play space below but it's a
little dangerous to
to take that risk so you're going to see
that in gunfight 2v2
gunfight 3v3 gunfight snipers only
gunfight blueprints and faceoff
and then next up you mentioned miami
strike uh again
i i mentioned feedback uh so for miami
um we've made it bigger and darker no
i'm i'm kidding uh we did the opposite
of that we
we took the feedback and for miami
strike we've given it the strike
treatment
and we've cut it down into its own brand
new map
the strike version on miami is going to
be focused around the alley that that
kind of location
in the garage it plays completely
different than the
og miami as i call it in play testing
i've been able to hold down a balcony on
paramore and and just keep people from
flanking through that alley
but we will also open up some new paths
so i don't expect it to just to be a
carve out of of what you play in miami
today and we feel like this is
this is the right approach so very
excited about that one matt before we
jump into
new modes i want to ask tony rattled
through a number of new weapons
which new weapon are you most excited to
bring to which new
map and why uh i feel like a real badass
when i pull out the death machine
uh in apocalypse it's just you know it's
the perfect setting
that weapon is very near and dear to my
heart and i just feel like a badass
you talked about the uh the death
machine being near and dear to your
heart
uh one of the things near and dear to
mine uh comes in the form of a mode
available launch week that i think a
few other people will be happy to see
return gun game
yes sir gun game is back uh you know
like some of the weapons that tony
talked about i don't think it would be a
black ops game
if we didn't have gun game in it for
people that may not have
played it before you're in for a treat
the core concept
is everybody has starts with the same
weapon which is going to be a pistol
there's going to be a total of 20
weapons you're going to finish with a
combat knife
for the default gun game and your goal
is to get a kill
with each weapon as you get a kill
you'll switch to the next weapon
and the first player who can manage to
eliminate an enemy with all 20 weapons
will win the match
so yeah that's what i'm really excited
about and we'll have some some fun
variants
coming later on down the road for gun
game stockpile
new mode coming in season what's in
store again it's one of my favorites
um one that we introduced i believe in
black ops 3.
originally it was called fracture back
then the the
the fiction was a bit different uh we've
grounded it
just like our boots and the goal for
stockpile is to kill enemies when you
eliminate an enemy
they will drop a small version of a dog
tag
unlike kill confirmed your job is not
done once you pick that dog tag
up you can pick up to 10 enemy dog tags
and you will
carry them on your person your goal is
when you pick up those dog tags
you will see a deposit site you need to
make your way to that deposit site and
stand in that deposit site
and you guessed it deposit those dog
tags into that site
for each dog tag that you deposit into
the site you will earn one point uh for
your team towards the score limit
that stockpile uh but i believe uh you
know
around march 17th which may be a you
know a holiday called st
patrick's we're going to have a themed
st patrick stockpile uh so you're not
going to be picking up dog tags you're
going to be picking up clovers
and the deposit site may have a pot of
gold with a rainbow coming out of it
so that you know that's some fun stuff
we like to do so last but not least
40 player hardpoint uh coming in season
what else is there to say man we're
we're very you know excited about
kind of in in injecting some of that
core multiplayer
40 player gameplay player account
gameplay the rules are going to be a
little different than normal hardpoint
four players on a team 10 teams you're
going to drop into
ruka alpine sanatorium
and golova and when you first drop in
you're gonna see three active hard
points uh for every player on your team
that is on an active hardpoint you will
you will earn score and core 6v6
hardpoint
you're you're not going to gain more
score for the more players that you have
on it
40 player hardpoint does make that rule
change
so it brings about some some interesting
tactics and and
nuance to it that's a big point
difference another big one
is that there will never be a contested
state you will know
when enemy players are on the active
hardpoint but you also got to keep in
mind
that they're going to be earning score
just like you are so it's really
important to
recognize that the enemy players are on
your hardpoint
and then go and find them and get them
off of there because again
it's all about racking up scoring
getting to that score limit
guys thank you very much for joining us
today we really appreciate it
we'll see you again soon for anyone
wondering what else might lie in store
for season two
feel free to check out the season road
map the road map
and additional season two information
and blog content can be found
at call of duty dot com there you can
also find information about battle pass
integration 100 tiers of new content
starting with naga
the battle pass system also features an
arsenal of weapon blueprints that will
light up the jungle
all unlockable as you progress from tier
0 to 100
new operator skins as well as new
weapons like the pharah 83 assault rifle
and the lc10 smg for information about
the latest game status updates feel free
to head to treyarch's trello page
just one of the ways our community
manager josh torres
is working to help the studio keep
players informed about the game
a big thank you to all of our
spokespersons today that made the time
to be with us
and thank you to the crew that made
today possible tommy allen
foxy and ben stay tuned to treyarch and
call of duty social channels for the
latest about in-game activations
and in the meantime have fun and enjoy
everything that season two
has to offer
you